- À Laval, on complète
la constructionde deux Maisons .
Mais l'île de Montréal n'en aura
aucune et la reconstruction
d'une demi-douzaine de CHSLD
vétustes s'embourbe.
DENIS CLOUTIER, Synd. des prof.
en soins, Est-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- Encore une fois, c'est
les deux poids, deux mesures.
On a fait un budget initial,
que je me rappelle bien, était
de 2,6 milliards. On a entrepris
la construction des Maisons
des aînés. Ces projets-là
continuent à avancer puis, nous,
à Montrit faire
les ajustements pour respecter
l'enveloppe globale.
'est de Montréal,
trois CHSLD très vétustes
ferment ou changent de vocation.
C'est le cas de Benjamin-Victor-
Rousselot dans Rosemont.
Le CHSLD Nicolet dans
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve sera,
lui, carrément fermé.
Et Jeanne-Leber, sur les
terrains de l'ancien Hôpital
Louis-H.-Lafontaine sera
aussi fermé.
- On est en discussion avec
le gouvernement par rapport
à la démolition de Jeanne-Leber.
- Il faut donc reconstruire
trois bâtiments qui compteront
670 chambres. En 2
la facture était évaluée
à 450 millions. Un an plus tard,
c'est déjà insuffisant.
Dans des documents obtenus
en vertu de la Loi sur l'acc sus
à l'information, la Société
québécois des infrastructures
écrit que :
Le CIUSSS va faire ce
qu'il peut avec des budgets
qui ne correspondent
plus au marché actuel.
JEAN-FRANCOIS FORTIN VERREAULT,
SSS Est-de-l'Île-de-Mtl
- C'est de construire
le plus de places possible
avec le budget disponible.
Donc, c'est clair qu'on a
des exercices. Fait qu'on es
d'optimiser. Je vous nommais
tout à l'heure le nombre
d'étages. Donc, en augmentant
le nombre d'étages, on comprend
qu'on est capables de faire
des économies. Donc, on est
dans ces exercices-là
à l'heure actuelle.
- Un défi partout sur l'île.
Le déficit d'entretien total
des CHSLD du Québec est
de 164 millions.
Mais 60 Mais 60 Mais 60 Mais 60e
des CHSLD de l'île de Montréal.
Le CIUSSS de l'Ouest-de-l'Île
pourrait aussi fermer
trois CHSLD trop vétustes.
Le CHSLD Grace-Dart,
inauguré au 19e siècle,
ou celui de Dorval, dont
une partie est centenaire.
Mais dans l'ouest de l'île
es coûts augmentent.
EMMANUELLE LEGROS, CIUSSS
de l'Ouest-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- On fait face aussi
à une surchauffe du marché
de l'immobilier, on fait
face à une surchauffe
des coûts de construction.
Donc, le secteur public est
affecté au même tître que
tous les autres secteurs.
- À preuve : ce terrain
de l'ouest de l'île de Montréal,
qui devrait accueillir
un nouveau CHSLD, acheté par
une entreprise privée
7,3 millril 2021,
il a été revendu au CIUSSS
de l'Ouest-de-l'Île
10,3 millions sept mois
plus tard. Construire ou rénover
des CHSLD est plus cher
que jamais, alors qu'on
compte maintenant plus de
4000 personnes qui attendent
une place en CHSLD, un nombre
qui grimpe à cha